welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast I'm here with Leonard Heim
Leonard uh could you introduce yourself
sure thanks for having me um yeah my
name is Leonard Heim I'm a researcher at
the center for the governance of AI in
short Cafe I and I'm working on a
research stream which we call I call
compute governance so I'm asking myself
to questions like where and why is
computer particularism promising note
for a governance can I do something to
computational infrastructure which might
allow us to achieve more beneficiary
outcomes for example looking at Hardware
mechanisms which could support this
regime without just like can we use
compute monitoring to yeah have more
responsible actors are there on the
iworld to start with is important it's
important to specify exactly what you're
worried about here so why in general
should we worry about AI what what's
your preferred framing for thinking
about AI risk yeah I think my preferred
way is like grouping in three categories
like this misuse risk accident risk and
structural risks right misuse if if
somebody is not using gbd4 to send like
a bunch of fishing mails accident risk
is like for example if a self-driving
car crashes in somewhere or we have like
some scenarios where like AI systems try
to do something on their own some
malicious tasks and structural risk and
like the things which are like
underneath the surface are just like I
don't know slowly all fall in love with
a chatbot maybe this might be good I
don't know if we are having a good time
but there are like many reasons to
believe something like these things
might eventually be bad right it's
slowly coming things which should like
definitely look out for perhaps we could
say a little bit more about the
structural risk so what are you actually
worried about here so yeah structural
risk I think we when we talk about AI
system we talk about like somebody often
the general purpose technology right so
it's going to be plugged in into many
ways how our economy Works how how
nation states compete with each other
even on a military's perspective right
and then these kinds of like structures
can change over time and they change the
Dynamics right
um there's something you could be saying
nuclear weapons have like in in like
increased to something like some kind of
structure risk you know there's like
some structural risks just like we have
them and they change the Dynamics of
warfare and I think AI might be like
similar in a lot of these cases this
might be like a structure risk regarding
military and how nation states compete
with which are on how we how we go about
war other structure risks are just you
could for example think about
recommendous systems with Facebook this
might be a structural risk if it just
turns all of us it's really addictive
but it turns out we are like really
miserable because of this so that's like
a wide variety of things like these slow
things which are like not immediately
clear that's like actually bad but over
time we actually see this playing out
it's like being bad what is the AI Triad
yeah yeah I try it or I also like to
call it AI production function basic
describes you have this this function
which has like certain inputs and these
inputs are those three things just Triad
um so that's compute data and algorithms
um with compute I mean something like
computational infrastructure you know we
need computation infrastructure data and
centers your smartphone your computer to
train and execute these systems with
data this is the data we eventually
train these systems on be it on a bunch
of images or a bunch of text and
algorithms generally describe machine
learning so systems right deep learning
within machine learning and with India
for example Transformer architectures or
other algorithms which eventually power
these systems which are trained on the
data using the compute we throw this
into the compute air production function
and out we get some AI systems which is
like certain capabilities right and
particularly air production function
tries to think about like how much do
these individual inputs matter and what
can they tell us about the capabilities
which I like to something the output of
this air production function yeah and
why is it you've you've tried you've
decided to to focus on the compute
aspect here in in compute governance
what is it that makes compute
specifically interesting from a
governance perspective yeah I think one
interesting trend is just like the role
of compute over time I think Richard
Saturn described it as the bitter lesson
where he talked about like well we're
trying to come up with this really cool
algorithm trying to model the brain but
actually the the bitter lesson is we
just do like some type of search
algorithms for more computer demo it
looks like it's just working so better
systems turn on to be formed better and
better systems means more compute and we
did an investigation where we looked at
like what is actually the computer
training usage of like cutting-edge
systems those who have like the best
capabilities those who have like a lot
of citations and what we found there
were the compute usage for training is
doubling every six months and something
doubling every six months means like wow
things like this is a really important
input
this was something like the empirical
motivation for these kinds of things
otherwise what I usually describe is
like computers some unique properties
and it has some unique State of Affairs
which makes it particularly interesting
governance note which I'm happy to
elaborate on yeah yeah please tell us
yeah so unique properties with unique
properties I'm usually saying well
compute is this rivalous product it's
like it's basically excludable so if
you're crunching numbers on your
computer nobody else can crunch numbers
on your computer if a data center is
fully utilized nobody else can use this
this is in contrast to data and
algorithms if I have a data in F
algorithm I press command or z a
Commando C Commando V and there we are I
got it twice this does not work with
compute I wish it would work like this
otherwise we didn't need this complex
supply chain it's still something
excludable right if I'm not giving you
access to your computation resources you
can't have it even if I hack into a data
center I can only use the computation
resources of a nobody else is using this
and B until the point they kick me out
whereas like if I hack somewhere else
and I try to steal the model I started
to see the algorithm I try to see the
data I have it I cannot exclude it later
on because I can just copy the other
aspect is the quantifiability I was like
well computers like somewhat nice
measurable and it's like the various
ways of measuring I can just ask myself
like how many eye chips of which type
has an actor access to because how many
chips they might have given the
computers important might tell me
something about the AI capabilities or
like which kind of access they have to
AI capabilities I can try to measure the
training computers I just described but
I can also just try to look yeah where
are the data centers who's using them
how many chips are there and which
actors are there so I have to something
like those who have a lot of computer to
something like those AI actors I I
should be like thinking about I should
be trying to govern and make sure they
build responsible AI systems they also
like the fundamental properties where
I'm claiming they stay the same over
time this is just a fundamental thing
about compute and this particularly
interesting compared to data and
algorithms like way harder to measure
these
um and you can't actually exclude them
yeah so computers is basically physical
and that makes it easier to control
you're not gonna have for compute
leaking online like the weights of a
language model can you're not going to
have a data set leaking online could it
be the case that for example the
knowledge used to produce these chips
could be leaked online and that would
make compute less controllable in a
sense or or is is the production of
compute very dependent on specific
hardware and and perhaps local knowledge
in in the factories and so on yeah this
this is on the on the second point which
I'm not calling the State of Affairs or
something right
um I'm like well computers being
produced by this really complex
concentrated supply chain and if you're
just saying well if there's like certain
IP not being leaked online can I just
build like the next tsmc in my garage
and my claim is like actually no you
can't it's like really really hard this
is a thing where like a lot of people
are thinking about right now you might
want to ask certain employees at asml
and asking about what they're doing in
their work and they might not be able to
tell you so they're paying a lot of
attention at like no IP is leaking from
these places we have history of certain
um people just like leakingism National
like providing it to China and then
China trying to use it and actually
trying to yeah eventually produce some
chips of it but it's still hard I think
they're still the case so it's like if
all of asml isps or like tsmc's IP would
leak tomorrow it would definitely make
it easier to build the chips where the
machine switch better chips or to be
eventually build the chips and
Fabrication I don't still think it's
sufficient we still have this tested
knowledge of these people who build
these machines we're talking about the
most complex machines in the world to
actually set this up yeah and this just
seems really really hard to eventually
build this or like it's some combination
I think we all would wish for the world
where like all of the organizational
knowledge is written down but guess what
sometimes we need to talk to each other
to bring certain things across or like
it's actually like sorry get out of the
way I need to I don't know tighten the
bullet on this machine
um because there's like some specific
way of going about it right symbolic
example here so it's very difficult
perhaps even if you wanted to to to leak
all of the intellectual property from
from these companies because perhaps
many of the engineers do not know or
can't describe what it what it is
specifically they're doing or a document
detailing what what they're trying to do
wouldn't would never encapsulate all of
the knowledge that they have about what
they're trying to do in indeed and
everybody just works on one small part
right I mean like we talk about just
like one machine which is built like by
thousands of people there's like
literally some person just like
responsible for maybe this one I don't
know there's one ball which is like
setting up the mirror in the right space
there right and the other one just like
trying to make sure that the laser has
like always exactly 12 volts or
something right this just keeps the
person busy
um so this one person might know how
does one component work but they rarely
have like the overview on all of this
works right this is like this is an
Endeavor of holy SML and it's an
Endeavor of haul off Humanity to some
degree to build these chips where we
like all come together we're trying to
put it into certain boxes right they're
different people designing it they're
different people like building the
machines they're different fabricating
it and eventually assembling it but
there's definitely some crosstalk there
and like within each of these units it's
like really really hard to just like
make it based off the IP and like steal
it and definitely people right now are
trying this right they're like people
trying to hack into asml dsmc and all of
the other companies trying to get as
much sip as they can and I hope they
just have like pretty good cyber
security and trying to prevent this do
you think do you think these companies
are actually investing enough in cyber
security because I mean compared to how
valuable their their IP might be of
course there's a general answer where no
one is ever investing enough in in cyber
security but yeah do you think it's
extra important for these companies a I
think it's extra important B Simon
security is really really hard you know
somebody yeah somebody with like a
background and then like it's really
really hard really it gets really really
hard if you need to deal with nation
states right it's not like some kitties
which are trying to hack you it's like
trying a nation stage which is like
trying to get certain IP is asml and
tsmc really trying hard yes
um I actually just watched the
documentary about asml on the plane but
like the CEO was complaining that just
like they spent more and more like
certain Millions just on securing their
IP well eventually it's an interest
Lucky them they're the only one building
these machines if so many of us would
get it it would not be good for their
business perspective so they're clearly
trying this in in this case right we
also have like unfortunate cases of
Nvidia being hacked eventually actually
just by some kitties this is what the
code looks like where a bunch of the
data has been leaked and I think Nvidia
should have probably had better cyber
security here and maybe like scale it up
like a lot because Nvidia is just a
design theorem there's just like just
something we can just steal the designs
and then copy them or something I think
there's like more to gain if you just do
the IP there's still some tested
knowledge but like there's more to gain
and eventually all of these companies
all of these companies somewhat involved
if you think about AGI and Ai and if
this turns all these systems are going
to be really capable in future just need
to step up the information security game
right and that's a key priority within
AI governance and within AI labs to
ideally be as safe as the military or
the NSA or whoever okay so when we talk
about compute governance in general we
have an option we want to know what
certain companies and labs are doing so
we want to to monitor how much compute
they're using for example in general
which options do we have available for
monitoring compute usage one way of
monitoring is like what they sometimes
just reported themselves but they're
just like hey we trained this new system
and use that much compute the reason why
I'm working on this because some AI Labs
taught me hey we trained the system it's
this big it used that much compute and
like oh interesting that's a lot of
compute this means you spend like single
digit millions millions just on training
these systems right to something we
either just put it out there we I think
we're hitting New Era now where like
they stop doing this right so like I
learned like look likes computers
important it's an important act there
and now let's stop doing this because
you just also push maybe dangerous memes
and give like away certain IP which you
have there the general knowledge
question is more compute usually means
more capabilities and then like well
more capabilities means more
responsibilities that's what I'm
advocating for so if I see those who
train the biggest models I'm like guys
you train the biggest models you have
the most compute you should also bear
the most responsibilities here this
could be self-reported this is like just
a company's just like telling someone
ideally maybe like some act on the
government and I think this would have
to be great Act of just foresight when
like people like hey you know what
government we just trained system X use
that much compute has this capabilities
raise yourself or prepare or whatever
you know like something along these
lines would be good for them to know so
they can have some foresight I think it
would be good to know for the government
to know GB France being released because
it might have certain implications on
your Society I don't think it's going to
be like a really big deal right now but
I think in the future will be more of a
deal about HS like security implications
and the governance should be
um eventually briefed on this beforehand
and we should probably also just mandate
it but it's like every use of computers
across a certain professional needs to
report her just like yep my
responsibility just tell me what's going
on there as the first step and later on
you could even mandate certain audits so
in either it's like hey you're just
trying to speak system could be could we
please have like a risk assessment
before you actually deploy this to the
world right and maybe in this latest you
could even like ask deny people training
certain systems whereas like they ask
you if I can train a certain system and
you might be like who are you actually
are you a responsible lap right and then
we have like maybe some ways of
eventually assessing this but again like
you could imagine this as a tiered
system with like different monitoring
with different regimes we eventually ask
him to do and it's unclear to me now
what is warranted but I think we should
definitely set up and play some kind of
infrastructure to eventually get the
started if it's warranted and I think we
have like more than enough reasons right
now that this might be a bit Rarity in
the future yeah it's pretty it's easier
to prove that you have something say
that you have three servers then then it
is to prove that you don't have
something so it's pretty pretty
difficult to prove that that you don't
have you know either some extra compute
hidden in the basement uh what What
mechanisms do we have here to to try to
verify that a lab doesn't have more
compute than that they say they do as
you say it's like easy to verify and
have that much compute you could even
imagine like run run this algorithm I
know you have that much compute it
should take you 10 seconds if I don't
get demands in 10 seconds I know I'm
gonna ask you where did your compute go
right where it's handled like if they're
hiding something in the basement I think
what we can do here is just like build
on top of the supply chain the supply
action is really concentrated there's
basically two types I mean actually just
one type of GPU sitting out there which
are Nvidia wants at least if you talk
about these Hardware you can buy there's
still a property Hardware like tpus or
like other and then we just check on the
supply chain because they're only that
many Fabs who produce these chips and
it's like Hey guys you're producing
these chips where are they going I'm
just gonna write it down and I know you
have this many chips so I'm gonna ask
you to prove this on time to time you
know maybe I visit you maybe I sent you
a proof of work different mechanisms to
eventually achieve this but we know how
to do traditional supply chain tracking
and this is needed anyways right now um
because of us export control reasons
which you might chat about later that
you just know where these types of chips
go who has access to them so we can then
do this and this yeah like traditional
supply chain tracking methods or we can
also just think about other methods
where we just like certain people like
the hardware only works if it tells you
where it is this might be more intrusive
but like something along these lines so
Geo tracking for for hardware and and
Geo locking basically for Hardware yeah
you you could mentioned something like
this if this eventually is oriented and
again I'm only talking about like a
small amount of chips here which is I
mean not a small amount of chip but just
like a small subset of all the chips are
being produced right within the AI chips
I'm talking about the chips which are
the high best performing chips which go
to Data Centers I'm not talking about
geo-locking anybody's smartphone or
computer or something don't find we talk
about like Industrial Hardware we've
just probably owned by 80 by a handful
of actors because yeah just have like
Cloud compute providers and others who
just own a majority of all of this AI
compute if you want to call it this way
so so one of the things that makes
compute interesting from a governance
perspective is is that it's very
concentrated there's a huge data center
it's it's physical it's it's it's large
physically large so so it's you can
probably see it from from a plane almost
what if say that I'm a lab and I wanna I
want to get around certain restrictions
I don't want someone monitoring my use
of compute could I could I distribute my
Computing over a large Network and then
train my um my AI models like that
perhaps it would be much less efficient
but it would perhaps also allow me to
circumvent a certain monitoring regimes
I mean first of all I would wish nobody
would try to circumvent this right maybe
it's like wish for thinking it was like
hey actually there is no downside to
this there's like benefit like
everybody's going to be doing this we
ideally mandate this world right and
everybody's on the same page too but
you're right when you do restrictions
when you do policies regulations
whatever people are trying to evade this
I think if this type of evasion we just
like try to in this case I think a
better terms like trying to de-train
decentralized it's always distributed
across many gpus but now we're just
trying to think about putting some gpus
location a and some other gpus and
location B the question is just feasible
there is research on this people are
trying this this is feasible there is a
penalty to this right the question like
is this penalty worth it if you want to
stay economically competitive and it's
just like your competitors are not doing
this and they can train like 40 cheaper
it might not be competitive right then
you rather follow the regulations to to
eventually achieve this if we go back to
the previous point where I'm just like
tracking initially where all the AI
chips go to like prevent this type of
smuggling or this type of misuse there
might be two different data centers I
might ask both this and I was like hey
who are actually your customers and then
just like oh you both gave that much
compute to customer a so I now have some
idea what is the biggest thing which
customer a try to train right so like we
need different mechanisms there but
again this is definitely one of the key
things we need to look for
um as a way to trying to evade this I'm
pretty pessimistic that you can just
like train it like at home or something
where you're just like everybody donates
their GPU at home these systems need to
talk to each other at fast speed
eventually then I don't know it depends
where you live but most people are like
kind of shitty internet at home um so
it's like really hard to translate all
of this data the data center is just
like this this like this this engine
which is like way more efficient it's
just always going to be like more cost
effective to do it in a data center
right yeah you mentioned these uh export
restrictions that the U.S uh have
recently imposed on exports to China
specifically uh also other countries
perhaps it's um mostly China I think is
the same I'm not sure if the same rules
apply to Russia but they're definitely
some sanctions to Russia where like more
people play along taiwanel so it has
sanctions to Russia yeah so what are
these export controls to to China I
think we can scope it into like roughly
four buckets so they prevented the
certain ships from going to China these
ships are classical AI data center chips
as is a100 or h100 they're not allowed
to be export to China anymore they
stopped the selling of semiconductor
manufacturing equipment for example this
asml company we we discussed
um it's not allowed anymore to say
abilities to China and then the Dutch
they actually pay along they agree with
this they stop selling it to China so
they cannot produce their own ships
right this is if you stop selling your
chips they incentivize to produce their
own chips so you're like oh I don't give
you accessible machines which produce
the chips so now they're trying to build
their own machines which build their
chips but now the US also has an export
ban on equipment which helps you to
build the machines which build the chips
right and lastly they also stop actual
U.S personal I think everybody with the
US Passport is not allowed to work at
certain companies anymore which fit into
this like broader scheme of the Chinese
semiconductor industry and that's a big
deal they're basically trying to cut off
access to
um producing Sovereign semiconductor
chips China can still buy most of the
chips the chips which are actually
banned and there's restrictions it's a
limited number of chips and this is
mostly chips I mean this is only chips
used in data centers for AI workloads
and maybe for some other workloads if we
want to take inspiration from these uh
export restrictions and say that
something similar could apply to a U.S
company what would be required for you
to say this is a good idea how how
Reckless would you would you see a
company behaving before you would pull
the trigger on a saying for example not
giving them access to chips because this
this seems like a a a pretty serious uh
action you know you you talked about
with with greater compute comes comes
greater responsibility but perhaps also
with with greater power over companies
comes greater responsibility so what
should we see from a U.S company before
you would be able you'd be interested in
in doing something like this as you said
this is a pretty intrusive measure right
and and it's a pretty blunt tool this is
not to forget should I pull this I
actually don't think so the reason why
the US eventually did this is because
other legal tools just don't work you
can write as many angry letters as you
want
it just doesn't run it's like hey are we
selling you Chips please don't give them
to the Army you know guess what we
figured out they end up at the army
anyways so you pull this blunt tour
because that's the only thing you can do
I think what's useful to think about
here is I'm you thinking about like some
kind of tech stack at the top I have
Services AI workloads computer
um facial recognition something below
there I have software computer vision
machine learning this kind of thing and
this Builds on top of hardware and
eventually what the US government wants
to achieve here they want to prevent
certain misuse and app used by these
systems against human rights being used
by the Army and a bunch of other things
and they can write an angry letter it's
like hey please stop doing this but
you're still allowed to do this it's not
gonna work but you can do this legally
in your own country you have different
Tools in your own country if the US
government sends an angry letter to open
eye or anybody else well they better
follow it right because they're sitting
in the same jurisdiction so you probably
don't need to use these blunt tools
where you just like cut off the access
to compute I think my argument is it's
one of the most enforceable notes and
sometimes you need enforceable nouns as
you say particular actors are
particularly Reckless another example to
think about this is you think about like
people running Silk Road like um drug
markets online you send them angry
letters but first of all like who do you
send his letter to because you don't
know actually who's running this right
um and if you figure out who runs it you
usually send them an angry later but
sometimes you just don't know who's
running this and then they just do this
blunt tool which which I call compute
governance so just unplug it they're
trying to figure out where the server
sits because this is sometimes easier
than actually finding a person who runs
it and then it just unplug it it's like
well you know we couldn't find you
you're doing this illegal thing
um you didn't respond to our letters we
couldn't send the letters so we're just
going to unplug the server right now so
like on the enforcement perspective
compute is like really really useful and
reasons for this is just like as a
backup option if the other things don't
work or maybe just as a layout defense
right to eventually have this and again
next to this enforcement tool they're
like other reasons like quantifiability
in these other things but but they are
like they look a bit different than this
disenforcement angle which I just talked
about yeah you could imagine a scenario
where say a a governance organization
and a company disagrees about how
powerful a model will be if it were to
be trained we could we could say say uh
gpt8 where where there's a disagreement
about which capabilities this model will
have and this is a general feature of
these machine learning models because we
we don't always know what's going what's
going to arise from them which
capabilities are going to arise we've
been surprised before so only I have I
probably you have too many people have
been surprised by by the progress we've
seen so given that we don't know which
capabilities arise beforehand how do we
know which training runs to restrict
yeah that seems to be a hard question
um I I will point to two things which
are like somewhat useful here there is
one thing where I would actually call
this like an open domain of research
which is like the problem is if you're
trying to stop a training run from
happening usually we have like something
we we make governance based on a Model
it's like oh this is a high risk model
because it makes decision about who gets
a loan who gets which medical advice and
then we make decisions based on this and
we run some evals or whatever we can't
do this here so what I might be
interesting is like maybe some
properties of the training run so one
question I could ask like how big is the
training I'm going to be because again
historically you've seen bigger training
runs bigger models have more
capabilities so all things being equal
those sort of things which should be
like more governed over like should be
used more responsible
in the future we might also learn more
about like certain aspects of training
runs which are particularly dangerous
right so once you maybe invent an
architecture where you have like some
sub architecture like which enables your
AI systems to have goals something wrong
design so you have like certain
reinforcement learning components or you
have like certain online learning
components these kinds of things I'm
like well all things being equal systems
with these kinds of properties should be
more of concern right so I want some
kind of verification of properties of
training runs and like then I can just
see what passes and this is like people
should try to learn more about this and
ideally we also have it in a way where
it can be done automated so the company
doesn't need to release the source code
like just like nobody sees them we do it
like in a privacy preserving way number
way how we do it how we usually deal
with these kinds of governance things is
we make it about the organization we
make it about the owner right if I'm
gonna sell you a gun and verse gonna do
a background check well I don't know how
you're gonna use it right but the
minimum thing which I can do is like
well
one have you done before are you a
responsible actor and this I think opens
up this whole government like this whole
work stream of corporate governance
which my colleague is working on it's
like what makes up a responsible AGI lab
what are the things they should be doing
so I load them to train a certain system
I could be saying hey you're only
allowed to trade a certain system if you
have an internal risk management system
right this this might be what good
government looks like we have the same
for banks you're only allowed to open a
bank if you announce certain regulations
this is just like I'm not Reinventing
the wheel we have this before I'm just
saying well maybe you should make this
about AI developers AI labs and maybe
compute as a way of verifying this I
think what I'm trying to push is like
this whole notion when I click we need
some kind of AI driver's license not
everybody I'm not allowed to drive a
truck and I think that's a really good
idea right and I should do some training
before I drive a truck the same goes for
AI systems I think not everybody should
train AI systems some corporate
structures are just like more
responsible than others and we know
which features make this up this is not
going to be foolproof but we learn over
time and we could get started on this
right now we're just like yep those
systems have an impact this makes you
more responsive this makes it less
responsible but these are the more
heavy-handed measures that we could take
so monitoring and restricting compute to
certain companies you've also explored
the option of promoting work in in
safety so how would this go you would
would you would subsidize compute for
for companies that you have reason to
believe are doing important safety work
yeah um I think this would be one
example where you're just like give
companies are like oh you know you're
the good guys I give you more compute
the problem we just have here does
safety work scale with compute and again
we generally have this really blurry
line between like what is safety work
and what isn't safety I think it's
definitely worth exploring right if I'm
saying like well we can restrict access
I can also give more access to others
and I think one prominent example of
this is we see more and more systems or
like nearly all systems which are
compute intensive which means most
systems with the most capabilities
coming out of research Labs coming out
of Corporations they're not coming out
of Academia anymore Academia simply
doesn't have the funds the teams and a
bunch of other things to build these
systems so what they're currently trying
to do in the US is called
internationally a research resources
near but like trying to figure out well
can we just give them more resources can
we just give them more compute right and
then you might be at arguments like well
academics they have like somewhat of a
different nature of research to do that
because compared to for example industry
right industry is eventually trying to
make money whereas academics is like
well we know that academic research is
way more diverse we know that academic
research is more like to produce public
goods so maybe they would be like more
incentivized so just like more
beneficially in Isis and like take a
closer look at this it's not necessarily
clear to me it might not just be that
they continue being part of this red
race we're just like trying to build
bigger and bigger models I do think this
is not the best idea to do because I
think it's like really expensive it's
not the best competitive Advantage for
linear it's not the best competitive
Advantage for academics wherever they
should be doing research just beneficial
this could include the more diverse
research which might help us with making
progress on safety particularly parts of
safety beat interpretability whatever
pick your favorite thing and then we can
fight over it if it's actually safety or
not it's always an ongoing topic they
might also just do some type of work
which are called just apply scrutiny
just like hey what about you download
Llama Or you use the gp4 API and just
like really point to the failure modes
of these models and giving them compute
for this might actually help right
there's a proposal which I wrote with my
colleague Marcus where we said well the
narrow that should give access to
pre-trained models from other
researchers but also from academics and
then academics can take a look at this
and take these models apart I'm not only
talking about computer scientists here
I'm talking about the whole scientific
domain which is basically now involved
in our research right but it's just like
what does this model mean for my domain
take it apart and point to the failure
modes so open AI or whoever can make
this model eventually better perhaps the
top Labs would be interested in having
this data because perhaps it could be
seen as you know if if we're discovering
failure modes this is this is one of
these things that might blur the line
between safety and capabilities work
where if someone some researcher at a
university discovers a a book or a fail
mode of a model that could be used to to
improve the models uh capabilities but
but also its safety there might be a
win-win situation here where this notion
of promoting safety work is less less of
a stick compared to uh
compared to restricting compute and more
of a of a carrot approach I think so I
mean just look at Twitter I mean
everybody's basically on better testing
gpt4 and just like trying to figure out
what's happening there and ideally you
should get paid for it or at least get a
PhD for it something along these lines
you should not have a better test on
Alpha test on the whole society maybe
you know maybe start with a small amount
of people and like I mean oh man I did
this to something right they like
delayed their release but maybe it's not
sufficient maybe like even more
responsibility in the future and
actually I don't want them to manage
this this is not a democratic decision I
want the government to decide what means
responsibility is and what it doesn't
mean could you talk a little bit about
the tech supported diplomacy I imagine
this means something like exporting
these governance options uh globally and
and yeah tell me what it means I I mean
something on the lines like using Tech
to reduce the social costs like a lot of
times we do stupid stuff because we
don't have enough information because
nobody wants to tell it us right this is
just like how many nuclear missiles does
X have well if we both have like
credible commitments this would just
like help us a lot right we invented
some tools to do it when I talk about
tech assisted stuff and I'm thinking
about AI I mean something like well can
we Implement Hardware enabled mechanisms
which allow us for actors to make
certain credible commitments like where
they actually have like technical proofs
there's like hey guys last year I
trained these many systems with this
much compute and then we say like cool
this looks good I was like oh this one
model I would like to take a closer look
at this we have like credible
commitments this could enable just like
labs to cooperate with each other where
it's like if Labs not cop like all agree
like hey guys let's slow down might be a
good idea you know let's go slower you
want the credible commitment you want
somebody to check on this right and what
I'm imagining to say you could imagine
like software enabled Hardware
enablement mechanisms which just proof
like hey here's the monthly report how
deepmind use their compute and then open
your checks isn't cool they they hold up
to their commitment this is great
because yeah we trust take more usually
at least it reduces the social costs for
trusting people then we do if we were
just like like tell each other and send
us each like happy emails where we like
do these kinds of stuff so like genetic
sandals and you could imagine this
across nation states across Labs across
many different actors but they have like
credible commitments about AI
development right and using compute
there as a tool to eventually enable
this so you cannot circumvent this right
like particular Hardware is like not
impossible to hang absolutely not the
case but definitely harder to hack than
software stuff and in terms of Technical
Solutions here so so that we don't have
to rely on trust what's available I'm
imagining some some perhaps some
cryptography where what is something
that's credibly neutral between Labs or
between companies or between countries
even because this is this has been a a
problem for decades in the nuclear space
where it's difficult to to for countries
to trust each other and there is no
neutral ground or technical way to prove
for example how many nuclear warheads do
you have so so what what's what's our
options here yeah let's try to to
piggyback this this nuclear thing I'm
like well we might I mean we technically
would have possibilities to use like
count the number of news but like it's
hard to hide but we technically do in
the case of Iran and other countries we
measure the level of enrichment of
uranium and if they enrich it high
enough the alarm belts go off right and
then whoever does something right
um so we have some wave it's like yeah
uranium disenriched fine only nuclear
power plants uranium or your guys we
didn't we didn't we decide not to do
this right that's why we have on side
inspections and they even set up
physical devices there which they
continuously monitor this and I think
that's the same thing which I'm pointing
towards here right they like those
things which I continuous monitored
where we trusted which eventually need
to be verified with on-site inspections
or something different along these lines
Okay so we've explored compute as a way
to govern AI but there's a question of
whether the compute might become less
and less relevant because
newer models will require less and less
compute do you think that Cutting Edge
models will continue to be limited by
Computing Hardware
I think so
um I think we have some reasons to
believe I mean this is historical we've
seen I even though we don't know the
exit now so gpd4 I'm I'm claiming here
hereby that it's probably used more
compute than gbd3 and maybe just like
probably a lot of compute that I could
not train in my basement I could
probably also on the training with all
of my statements what's definitely Ryan
what you said over time to achieve
capability X the compute required for
this goes down over time right but what
we've historically seen just people
continue pushing compute more and
capabilities more than everything the
question is like what is the capability
where it starts to be like worrisome
right where it's like ah like yeah
actually like which needs to be governed
right and like if this goes down over
time what do we do about this so for
example maybe in 10 years from now I
might be able to train Jeep before and
then the question is like well how good
is gbt6 compared to gbd4 it's gp4 just
like worthless because already gpd6 is
along there this is an important
question just the general Notions like
how does the offense defense balance of
like more cutting-ages actually balance
off and if we're lucky these Cutting
Edge systems can defend across the other
systems this is what we need to see
right if this is the case for cyber
weapons is it the case for AI systems
which like develop dangerous pathogens
anything along these lines
if we look at the compute trends when do
you think approximately that say I have
the newest gaming computer when would I
be able to train a gpt4 level model at
home yeah I mean we can try to Crunch
the numbers I don't know where's Tubidy
for it's like it's like 1 to the power
of 25 flop or something then then your
GPU at home currently has what is it
like 300 teraflops assuming you're
getting a 100
um if we continue like if Moore's Law
continues
you could do it at home probably within
the next
six years if you're like happy to wait
like a couple of months and algorithmic
efficiency like make sure just like this
continues to go down so algorithmic
efficiency is like more important here
than than how your compute develops
right you have a bit of heartburn like a
couple of years but you're also just
like algorithmic efficiency made
training gb4 just like way cheaper right
so I guess this will be possible at some
point like at home unsure right like at
least some point it was it's gonna be
cheaper maybe yeah we could crunch your
numbers I cannot do it in my head right
now but this is definitely possible to
do it's not a super important whether
it's at home but says for for something
that's more attainable for for an
average person say say a training GPT uh
GPT four level model for five thousand
dollars or something like this that's
that's that's that's coming within
perhaps six years this is not a long
time of course in AI as six years is a
million years but in in the in terms of
real world impact this is this is pretty
close uh so what is what is the Hope
here is it that GPT 6 or a model like
that will be able to detect the the
misinformation or the the phishing
attacks coming out from from gpt4 Models
trained at home you you could imagine
something in these lines right we're
just like well the defense of these new
model is like really really good right
you could also just imagine a world
where just like AI compute becomes more
specialized so the GPU you have at home
in the future is like actually not that
useful for training like these new
systems
um like it depends how this will develop
we already see like some kind of
Divergent there your GP at home looks
different than this Nvidia a100 so like
let's not count on the six years there
um the thing is with like exponential
growth we also have like sometimes
exponential times there or something
um I'm happy to follow up with the
number there
um yeah I can't do it in my head right
now this is what empiric looks like we
can't continue pushing just like
spending more computer on these kinds of
systems I never said this is gonna be
easy nobody ever said AI governance or
there's hardly anything is going to be
easy or what I'm saying is like look
guys here's an interesting governance
note I think it has some unique
properties it's good at some things it's
bad at others compute is not the
solution to the AI governance problem
it's part of the solution it might give
you some nice tools that might give you
tools to get International agreements
and hopefully some of my colleagues are
figuring out these International
agreements or agreements against lab and
the people in the government like we all
work together and I'm like you know I'm
giving one piece of the puzzle I was
like hey look yes compute here how it
might help and here's how it might be
one defense layer out of many yeah let's
touch upon some potential problems with
compute governance and these problems
are in a sense just problems with
governance in general but just if we're
talking about who's doing the governance
of compute U.S Labs would probably be a
bit worried if if their compute was
governed by China and Chinese Labs might
be worried if their compute was covered
by the US government so do you but but
it seems like for this to work you would
have something close to a global system
for for compute governance so who who's
doing the governance and and how do you
get everyone on board yeah
um how do you get everyone on board I
mean what we can say right now the US is
governing China's compute this is
happening right now independent if you
agree with it I think it's a good idea
just like that's the status quo how do
they do this well they leverage certain
choc points across the supply chain but
they also do with the Allies if the
Dutch and the Japanese wouldn't play
along this wouldn't work right so like
this to something you like already oh
those three countries are like hey you
know what be like you get together and
we're trying to do this thing there
we're like trying to achieve and use
unfortunately this type of blunt tool
which which we need for this
um who's eventually doing this type of
compute governance I think first of all
will always be hard for countries to
build their own Sovereign semiconductor
supply chain right A lot of times you
just have like regulatory flight and
they build up their own whatever I was
like yep but what this is not going to
work for compute right I think a bunch
of people ask me like well if you try to
like control cocaine they're just gonna
do it in Mexico and other countries and
then they smuggle across I'm like yep
seems right but building like making
cocaine is like way easier than building
these types of chips I think this will
then just help so it looks like it'd
always be like will be an effort of like
the whole Global World to build these
Supply chains and eventually we can all
coordinate on this and actually agree on
this and then we just have like other
chalk points where just like if you look
at the current chip designers right now
who are leading there it's Nvidia it's
AMD those are the leading companies
there so I might not even need all the
governments to sign up for this I might
only need a responsible Nvidia where at
least in the beginning gives people the
features to eventually do something
along these lines right maybe we don't
even need to mandate it in the beginning
maybe need to mandate it later later but
for example Nvidia should like stop
start thinking right now about this if
there's like certain race how we can do
this which might be used Maybe not maybe
it's all turns out gonna be okay and we
don't need it but I think we should
definitely prepare
um that these kinds of systems are being
used and eventually all of this I'm not
saying Nvidia should control it
eventually we won't like governments and
Democratic systems to control this right
and I think that's a general thing we
jump around like yeah it seems good if
Democratic societies eventually decide
on this seems at least better than if a
dictator is deciding who's having so
much compute and lastly there might be
even ideas where just like I think a
bunch of people are thinking about like
well there is a one hectare or one
entity who's not controlling the compute
you could set up a third party right we
have the iea for nuclear stuff maybe you
have like an international compute Bank
in the future which will be doing the
stuff like based on an agreement maybe
you and maybe whoever something along
these lines and you could also enable uh
think about mechanisms which are like
self-sustained you're basically say hey
I'm selling you this chip and the ship
is going to do X if you do y whereas
like this chip is not going to allow
certain training runs across a certain
size so it's not the US government
pressing the button to stop it it's more
like no this is what we agreed on this
is just what the chip does there's like
no way around it of course this is like
really hard from a security perspective
right you need might need some on side
inspections regimes for this eventually
to work so would you be worried that a
government for example under the
pretense of being worried about AI risk
it uses these AI government measures to
say cement their military Advantage so
for example this could be any government
but say the US government says that we
need to restrict other governments or
other countries ability to make AI
progress because we're worried about AI
risk but really what we are trying to do
is to is to maintain uh you know U.S
homogeny and and U.S military power I
think that's definitely a thing one
should be worried about right if they
just cut off X's and I just like then
put all of the chips in our pocket and
use it or just like every computer is
monitored except the US military's
computers not monitored I think
eventually we need something like
everybody signs on and again it's I'm
not saying the US has a chalk functional
supply chain no no my countries have
chalk points across the supply chain
right and this is like then just how one
way or you can just like pressure each
other I mean maybe not pressure just
like talk each other into this
um and eventually get this so what about
on the company side uh again I'm worried
about you know institutions pretending
to have uh good motives pretending to
have good intentions about preventing AI
risk but actually having underlying uh
different motivations so here I'm
imagining the the current top players in
the in the field using this AI
government regulation to avoid
competition or to just uh maintain their
market dominance and this is some this
is an economic phenomena that we we in
my opinions have seen in other areas and
and could we also see it here
I think that's a real problem with like
any type of Regulation you usually have
sometimes certain regulations like favor
big players because they're just having
easier time to play it along I think the
status quo is just already that we just
have like certain Labs leading right now
and it's not the case that right now
anybody who can enter the field can
compete just as an example all the major
ilabs are partnered with a cloud
computing provider so they all just like
looks like compute is important looks
like I need a special partnership right
open my eyes with Microsoft Microsoft
has their own compute Google has to
uncompute deep mindsets within Google
they're also using Google Cloud hugging
faces with AWS for Amazon web services
so this is already a various entry which
is like they can only have that many
partners and anybody else who wants no
access on cloud compute from cloud
providers because this is technically
the only way how you get access to this
which is like somewhat price competitive
they just have bigger costs because they
don't have the special Partnerships
right so like they're already facing
this dilemma right now to some degree
and eventually all of this trades off
right if I just have like do I want like
um yeah like a great competitive
environment where everybody can compete
you know we get the best AI systems
we're like well actually you know what I
don't want this competitive environment
for AI systems because I think it could
be a race to the precipice and this
doesn't look good right so I might just
actually take the cut that have like
bigger companies there have like just
more power but eventually I want them to
verify what they do I want to have them
prove by math my Hardware that they have
these verifiable commitments right we
should not say oh yeah up my deepmind
are the good guys you know they play
along I think we live in a happy world
where they take certain risks serious
this is great I'm not saying that taking
it serious enough and then we just add
another layer on top of it where we just
mandate this kind of stuff do you worry
that governing compute could drive
Innovation from from more responsible
countries to less responsible countries
say that the more responsible countries
Implement some form of AI governance but
this just drives AI progress to less
scrupulous countries yeah regulatory
refined is a thing people leave
countries people live in certain places
of lower taxes but they don't live in
any place right it's like oatmeal and
the others they're like they're not
sitting in any they don't sit in country
with the lowest taxes even though you
might have they have incentives there
they're in centers playing along you
want to sit in the bay because the
talent is there because the people are
there because people want to live there
your AI developers want to live in a
nice place right they they care about
this kind of stuff so they cannot go
just anywhere right
um then I think just some of these
companies like X just like feel they are
American or something you know like
maybe that's a thing I guess maybe maybe
it doesn't stop once incentives are
different but independent of that there
there was just a case where if they
don't play along and this is like the
unique thing about compute we have this
concentrated supply chain so we just
stopped the AI chips going to Country X
you're worried about this is just the
thing we're going to do and if somebody
sets up the like the AI Haven with like
no regulations or whatever on the
Bahamas or something along these lines
yep then the chip stopped going to the
Bahamas um I think it's a blunt tool but
it's eventually the tool we then need to
use and this might be the only tool we
have and again this is better than
um some other measures you could imagine
and of course discussing all of this
this all of this depends on how
seriously we believe that we should take
AI risk I think the two of us agree that
we should take AI risk pretty seriously
but not everyone agrees with this so
your willingness or the willingness that
we should have to use these tools of
course depends on on the risk we see so
so that but that's in a sense a whole uh
separate discussion that I've had a
number of times on this podcast here
here's a a worrisome scenario say that
uh in the 60s the US was on on a path to
producing a lot of nuclear power plants
and thereby getting clean and green and
then cheap energy but
um this was prevented by regulation that
that's now mended made it very difficult
uh to to build new new uh new nuclear
power plants
and perhaps this regulation was well
intentioned and perhaps there was some
real danger but also perhaps also some
misunderstanding uh conflation between
nuclear weapons and and and
um nuclear power plants or exaggerated
fears about the actual dangers of of
nuclear and so on could this whole AI
worry lead us to a similar situation
where we we could have benefited
enormously from from all the Innovation
that we would have gotten from AI but
because we were in a sense too worried
more worried than was actually warranted
by the evidence we killed off an
industry that's definitely a downside I
think that's a downside with anything
how can you change this well you changed
your mind over time I think what I'm
trying to propose is like well we don't
go Full Throttle all of these things
it's like we should think about tiered
system which eventually help off with
this like hey we start with this and I
think some things are just warranted
right now they're just like companies
reporting their training runs and
reporting a compute usage I think is
like can be argued for right now at
least as an optional measure to these
kinds of stuff and discuss to the
government with the powerful of these AI
systems are there more extreme things
which have it as Cassidy varianted to
something we see them already playing
out right us is governing the computer
of China it's happening so we rather
have a good idea why it's happening and
just like trying to change our mind over
time if it turns out AIDS doesn't work
or B it doesn't achieve your God I hope
they change their mind so they get the
AI chips back and can do like whatever
like the good things with them right so
we just need to continuously look at
like the type of evidence we have and
maybe I'm like a bit naive there maybe
I'm too optimistic that we can just like
continuous to do this but this is like
this is what my job is about right that
continues to check the risk landscape
I'm trying to prepare for like some
kinds of things which might happen if
they're not him hooray don't get me
wrong this would be great right and then
I try to roll back or I have some
measures which I just never activate
right that's why I have like this
t-tiered system step letters something
along these lines I think in general we
should like stay better saved and sorry
and like complainer compared to nuclear
power plants the stakes for AI are
significantly higher compared to
mistakes for nuclear power plants I was
like this seems very into it I'm I'm
fine with like taking some cut on these
types of stuff if we have sufficient
evidence a thing about this just
forgotten like right now we're racing in
this kind of answers and we have no clue
how they work right Twitter is on it
Twitter's currently figured out and like
every day we find something new we had a
merging capability and how these kinds
of systems work and as long as it's the
case and as I get seems totally fine for
me to actually push the brake pedal and
think more careful about these types of
stuff
Leonard thank you for coming on this has
been super interesting for me thanks for
having me